what do you think most people go wrong
in telling their personal stories too
much information too little too much
information or too little possibly each
but getting back to what we're talking
about is yeah there could be too much
information which about the events and
all of that which actually masks what's
really going on in the character or they
could be too little information about
the character here's but here's the a
real key many times when we're doing
these workshops and working with
somebody who's doing this kind of
writing I will say quite honestly to
them it's a great story but you're not
in it and they'll go what do you mean no
no I was there and I told you that I
said no no you were there you were the
observer the way you told the story you
were the observer more like a journalist
you were the observer and you told us
all the details and you gave us a little
indication like oh yeah in that moment
oh and I was really scared or something
like that and I go okay but the thing is
you are not really in the story you have
kept yourself out of the story now this
story that the this person has told
quite possibly could be a very traumatic
story frightening one of those stories
that generates a lot of fear and now
what can happen as a result of telling
the story like that is as you're telling
the story even keeping yourself some
very much out of the story all those
fears will come back because they're
you're it's it's wired into your system
those fears and everything's in your
body and you are stimulating them again
and so you will feel the Thira feel the
joy feel the confusion whatever as
you're telling the story the problem is
you will think that the audience is
feeling the same thing and I can tell
you right now they're not they're not
there's no reason for them because
they're not you they will each member of
the audience will be feeling whatever
they feel they say oh that that's funny
well that's that's kind of sad there's a
wide range of what they could be feeling
I think autobiographical the goal of
autobiographical storytelling is can I
tell you a story can I tell you a story
like about my 10th birthday and such a
way that I can take you through the
story and you are moment by moment
feeling and experiencing exactly what I
felt as the ten-year-old at that moment
while the story is being told without
telling you Oh in that moment I felt
really scared then you know that's just
a piece of information that will not
stimulate a feeling within you my job as
the storyteller is to stimulate emotion
within you not just give you information
so this when you ask about too much
information too little information it's
usually too little of the real meat that
we want which is what is going on inside
the character I want to know what you're
thinking or feeling most people won't do
that they just want by instinct they
won't do that it's sort of a
preservation instinct so then we will
listen to the story and we'll have our
own reaction to it based on our life
experience that's it which really we got
to which we talked about with wise
people like certain films and certain
stories now you could tell a story to a
group of a dozen people without having
yourself really present in the story and
those dozen people have about a dozen
different reactions to the story based
on their life experience as if if this
had happened to them this is how they
would respond but the more powerful
story is they know exactly how you were
feeling how you were responding and now
they're not responding to just the story
they're responding to your experience
your emotional experience through the
story and that's much more powerful was
there a story that had power over you
that then you were able to tell so many
times and then you switched it and now
you had power over that story that was
your story
well you know in the thirty years of
doing this is that what you mean yeah
yes I mean I've been doing this for 30
years and one it's a great question
Karen and one thing I realized very
early on when I started to work either
with individual performers doing solo
shows or work with a group like a
workshop or even a larger group what I
was asking all of those writers or those
artists of those human bees those people
to do was dig into their past have a
story and it's not to really explore it
in a very open raw vulnerable way and in
order to really ask them to take those
little bit that leap the best way I
could help them do that was to tell my
own stories so I would always in every
workshop tell a story or beat or tell
several stories to give them examples
not only of how the story works or how
their storytelling techniques which I
was trying to teach them work but it's
that simple thing and this it has to do
with directing don't ask an actor to do
something that you're not willing to do
yourself so I couldn't ask these people
to write something that I wasn't willing
to do it so I need to do it and do it in
front of them and many times during that
I would purposely set myself a high
challenge just in terms of the story
that I would pick or the what I was
going to talk about I would push myself
to say can I go a little bit further can
I go away can I get into a more
dangerous area and there was one time
and Elsa was there that I told a story
in Hawaii that had happened just two
weeks earlier which was devastating to
me it was a devastating story and it was
humiliating and brought a lot of shame
to me and embarrassment and I'd only
told one person about it my sister who
was also in the workshop at that time
and but basically I was hiding it from
the rest of the world and then I decided
in that workshop I was going to tell a
part of that story and I did and it was
a struggle it was hard but it was
liberating and so yes that's you know
I've had that experience many times
going wow now I've done that I can I can
do it again so that my assessment that
telling tough stories traumatic stories
embarrassing or shameful stories again
and again and again the the balance will
change I've also experienced that within
my own storytelling have you seen there
were some people have they're just
unabashedly open about everything I mean
they're just people that I'm just
shocked they would put something on
Twitter but they that's just who they
are as human beings there's no shame
everything's an open book maybe they
came from a family that's like that and
so that's how they communicated whereas
there's other people that they're afraid
to tell you what they had for breakfast
right and they're super reserved and you
feel like every question you ask even
about the weather is somehow a personal
intrusion did you see those people
interacting at your workshop together
and just just you know the ones with the
arms crossed where it's not even that
they they don't like somebody but
there's just that's who they are they're
just maybe not as trusty and other
people that they'll tell the cashier at
the store some intimate detail from
their love life yeah I mean the thing is
in the workshops we get a whole range of
people and it's interesting because they
they just using your two examples the
one who is just the ones who just will
blurt out anything personal and the
other ones who are much more reserved
and afraid to even tell you their
birthday or what it whatever it is we
get that range definitely that range the
first thing that's really interesting is
at the beginning of the workshop what we
do is we check in with each person in
front of everybody not not privately why
they're there what they what they really
want and just sometimes hearing what
they want is interested in very quickly
we get a sense of the personality and
Bielsa and I have talked to this person
beforehand or met them online or
something so we have a sense of who they
are before they come in the workshop but
we we we check in with them to see what
their goals are and we get a sense that
this one is very reserved and with this
let's say this woman is so reserved and
as you say sort of like that that's not
gonna talk about anything and we say
wonder why she's here and but then we
have a feeling this is gonna this
workshop is going to be tough for a
shopper and sometimes that person will
by the end of the three days it's just a
three day workshop will explode and
something will come out and sometimes my
feeling is there they're unconsciously
because they want to release now on the
other end the ones who will explain say
everything expose everything we have to
watch them carefully too because they
can take over we have people who come in
and want to show us how it's done
and we know they're going to run into a
shock but when we start talking to them
about some of the things I've talked to
you about they go what do you mean I
don't know myself and there's another
part of this which we can talk to you
and I can talk about today about how we
use interrogation in this process but
because we interrogate that person if I
were to interrogate you as the 12 year
old the one that answered the door for
one day to the door so this woman over
here is telling a story about herself
and whatever and then we interrogate her
at that time now suddenly she's aware
that she has she's not as free as she
thought she was then there's and and
that person will go most likely go
through a change during the three days
and there's another huge part of this
workshop is that it's a workshop there
were maybe a dozen people there and
every single person is working on an
autobiographical story every single
person is struggling with their own
obstacles their own resistance their own
self-esteem whatever it is they're
struggling with this so you're in
that is really rather unique the energy
in the room is extraordinary
so that shy one who won't say anything
is being encouraged by the ones others
and she sees who are struggling who
would make breakthroughs the the one who
thinks she knows and everything is also
going to benefit by experiencing what
the other ones are going through so
that's a big part of the workshop is
just to be in that environment for those
three days and be immersed in that world
of autobiographical storytelling and
struggling with your own story writing
your story rewriting a story listening
to other people seeing them make
breakthroughs seeing them not make
breakthroughs and not be able to get
through an obstacle and seeing how
frightening that is all of that impacts
everybody so the truth is when Elsa and
I do these workshops we have no idea
what's going to happen we do the
workshop pretty much the same way every
time but then after it's all over LC and
I sit down and discuss could we improve
how can we change what new things could
we try and we'd come up with some new
things but pretty much generally it's
the same thing it's the environment that
the people are plunged into that causes
the change interesting so the extrovert
that is is a free spirit and tells
everybody everything can learn from the
reserved introvert arms crossed and vice
versa
yes yes and the extrovert may learn very
graphically or just very subtly that
hurt explosion of stories that she puts
out is actually covering up the story
she's not revealing anything except an
ego is it a defense mechanism know how
hard it could be I'm just saying could
be I don't know it depends on the person
but I'm gonna tell you this and I'm
gonna tell you that and i'ma do you
remember the the the film American
Beauty yes remember Angela the the
little cheerleader
oh yes who was just talking about her
sexual exploits forever and ever and
ever and ever and ever until the end
when she said this is my first well that
was a cover
those stories the story she was telling
was a cover-up for her insecurities that
she is as she said ordinary she was
afraid of just being ordinary that
nobody would want her so she creates
this whole myth about everybody wants
her right in West Bentley who is a drug
dealer I guess in the kind of almost
down places intelligence anyway and you
don't realize how deep and like feeling
he is but I don't know it's been a while
since I've seen it but I love it yeah so
I mean that's just an example
so yeah the extrovert and the introvert
will learn from other ending and the the
extent of what they learn may not
resonate within them two weeks or months
later because of this experience they
may start to see things differently they
may start to tell their stories
differently who knows it's very powerful
and it is a healing process in the first
workshops I did in Hawaii the first few
years there was a married couple I think
was Mary and John I think that's a name
anyway and they took it for several
years
very couple they were very unique only
in one way they would each have their
story they were going to tell and as we
learned quickly after the first year or
so that John would start telling the
story and the thing that was watching
Mary because Mary has probably never
heard this story before they would each
tell stories in the workshop that they
had never told each other before and by
the end of several years the last time I
saw them they said that workshop made
such a difference in their marriage you
know because it gave them a safe place
to be more open and more available and
more transparent
you